hey it's Evan I'm doing another one of
my Fiverr gigs where I'm reviewing
somebody's website and today it's
somebody that I know it's from dr. Anna
Baranowski was one of the members of my
mastermind coaching program so she
ordered the gig here on fiber and wanted
me to review her site so and I will see
I'll see what's going on with your site
and give you some feedback so at the
website you want me to look at is
tickler calm so we'll take a quick look
pop it up here now I know a little bit
about Anna's business from the year
she's been in my program but I'm going
to pretend like I have no idea what's
going on here so right away I look at
the homepage and I noticed a message in
here so online training for trauma
professionals so that's great and that
it explains what you do but it's not
really impactful but it doesn't hit me
there's not even a benefit here there's
no feeling that I get from reading that
statement so it's better than a lot of
websites they don't even explain what
they do but this could be a lot stronger
in making a connection with me as a
reader to say yes I believe in this and
I need to learn more about it I'm never
a huge fan of stock photography so here
at the top we've got this leave a
message thing that's not what Anna looks
like you know this is the seminar it's
not her seminar I always like you know
if you're going to use pictures it's
great and they don't always have to be
your pictures but not the stock
photography where people know that you
know they're just models being used here
so I try to upgrade the quality of your
pictures a little bit it looks cluttered
so I'm not sure what you want me to do
next ok so this follow us here signup
login there's a huge top nav with tons
of pull downs there's three boxes here
with different links there's a video
newsletter tons of stuff so this should
be clearer like what do you want me to
do next to come to the site i'm a little
a little overwhelmed i like that you you
have this logo this leaf you're using it
in your pictures which is great instead
of bullets i love the use of the logo so
that's that's awesome keeping the brain
consistency there but again I kind of
shorten this down you don't have
actually had that much
saan here this is your only messaging
but there's tons of call to actions and
i'm not sure what to do when i come on
the site it's a little confusing looking
down here you write this message I guess
is under your newsletter helping you
help trauma survivors today this is a
little more powerful so this is better
than online training for trauma
professionals helping you help trauma
survivors it's still not great but it's
way better speaks more to the benefits I
still not getting a feeling from it but
it's more the benefits of what you do
instead of just what it is that you do
with the training so that's a little bit
better this shouldn't be buried this
should be you know more prominent and I
definitely work on the messaging a
little bit more and then scrolling down
and notice you have here it's designed
by this company they probably threw that
in there unless they they paid for that
you might want to look at that because
that's your only external link and it's
going to your website designer so I you
know they'd probably fit on there
without you knowing so you probably want
to talk about that and see if you're
getting if you got some kind of discount
for that than fine but otherwise that
look at taking that off so let's look at
a inside page and see what we can find
let's look at about us and see what pops
up so about us this is great so a lot of
information I love that you have this
part here what our students are saying
and you've got a quote on here
testimonial somebody that has used it
social proof is amazing this should be
on the homepage maybe this on the
homepage let's take a quick look back so
you've got this what our students are
saying and then some stock picture I
miss this right the home page is so
cluttered I miss one of the most
important things which is the
testimonials from people are actually
using what you're doing and finding
value in it so again you know your your
there's so many calls auctioneer that
I'm getting confused and probably not
taking the right step let's go back to
our story so this is great you know some
information on here scroll down so
here's Anna here's a picture looks
authoritative I know that's the history
channel whatever you've got going on
here so that's great I might want to put
another bio picture of you smiling so
this is great to show the the you know
social proof hey I've been on T
yeoman recognized expert I'd also love
to see you smiling right I know you have
a great smile I see it on a regular
basis so I'd love to see that come
across so you know the friendly side of
you as well in here reading this so okay
you know you're the CEO you know your
background your guiding principle this
this section is weak okay what I'd love
to see here is why did you start this
business and write it in the first
person instead of dr. baranowski
received her doctorate in clinical
psychology say I started this business
because I believe in X like what's
missing in the market what do you feel
and why did you really start this thing
have a little bit of passion in here
that's what is going to come across
you've already done a lot of the heavy
lifting where you have a story you have
a picture a lot of entrepreneurs don't
even do this step is just a traditional
corporate boring about us page have a
smiling picture and tell me what some
passion why you started this business
what you're hoping to accomplish you've
impacted a ton of people and that
doesn't come across here on this side
it's very it's very boring so i
definitely look at switching up that
messaging you can also get the SEO so in
your title tag here you have
traumatology institute at the top again
so you don't need that at the top of all
your pages i probably take it off
completely because you're probably going
to rank for that anyway so put in
keywords that are more relevant to the
specific page and move it all the way
over to the left let's look I have a
page let's go free information so we've
got here giving stuff away free a little
bit information here following links
resource materials and courses developed
for your personal use on your trauma
recovery journey so now I'm a little
confused i thought this website was
about people who are trauma
professionals helping people who have
trauma right you have it here helping
you help trauma survivors and then this
is a series of resources for people who
have trauma they're not the professional
so it's just a little confused as to who
your target audiences are you trying to
target the people who have trauma or the
people who are servicing the people who
have trauma and if you're having free
information it should be around your
customers who are the trainer's right
the people who are dealing with the
people who have traumas
might want to reject this around put a
picture if you can with each one have a
little bit more of a description so
audio recording download you know
doesn't really tell me much about it so
put a little bit more information with
each one that you have here and then
let's look at some of these stories so
that kind of attracted me here with this
sidebar so this is great you know you
have people saying great things about
your business great things about working
with your website this is a little
condensed I think about breaking it up
adding line breaks on here to make it
easier maybe bolding the most important
sentence all this because this is a huge
paragraph that I wouldn't read so pull
out the most important quotes either cut
down the whole thing or just bold the
most important line from here and if you
can try to put their picture so if you
have a full name so you here we have
Donna rhymer let's see because it's it's
a lot better we can have a picture of
somebody so Donna rhymer is a registered
nurse passion compassion fatigue
specialist I do a search this might be
Donna yat recipients and she's a nurse
this is probably her psychiatric nurses
so like you got a picture here she's
smiling she's wearing a you know
professional outfit their use that
picture that's going to speak so much
more to the people reading this page
people will draw in towards a smiling
face and it's more believable so you've
got look you've got like a whole page
full of amazing testimonials but
probably people aren't going to read any
of these things because it's difficult
to read nothing's bolded there's no
pictures so it doesn't draw people in
you've done most of the heavy lifting
here it's just presenting it in a way
that people will understand and relate
to a lot better so that's my quick and
quick impression of the website and I
hope I wasn't too hard on you there but
give you some ideas on what to do to
make this thing even better and have an
even greater impact for those are
watching if you liked the video please
give it a thumbs up below and I'll do
more similar videos and if you have a
thought about this website or you have a
question for your own business please
leave in a comment section below I
always read those love seeing them come
in thank you guys I'll see you on the
next episode